[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
bien esto
que ven ahí
es el trofeo que se le otorga al campeón
mundial de un deporte muy popular
llamado softball
esto es el símbolo
que encierra un sueño
enciendo el sueño de todos los
deportistas que participan de esta
especialidad ese sueño en algún momento
este trofeo en algún momento fue nuestro
sueño
y nuestro sueño se hizo realidad ese
momento que vieron recién saltando a
manuel es el preciso instante de la
última acción que nos coronó y que
pudimos finalmente alcanzar lo esto que
ven ahí esto que sigue aquí es el
capitán del equipo levantando ese trofeo
levantando ese sueño
por último
el equipo completo abrazado
pleno de felicidad
habiendo recorrido todo un camino que lo
llevó a alcanzar finalmente este sueño
pero que entendemos por sueño
es un anhelo personal es un alivio
colectivo
no hay sueños más importantes que otros
el sueño más importante es el que tiene
cada uno y eso tiene que estar bien
claro porque si hay algo que hay en el
mundo si hay algo bien en esta sala y en
los miles que nos están viendo eres
soñadores sin lugar a dudas hay
soñadores ahora
lo difícil que parece muchas veces
alcanzar lo que uno quiere si aquello
tan complicado que parece ser alcanzar
aquello que yo deseo aquello que yo
anhelo si hoy
hoy vamos a tratar y vamos a enfocarnos
en un momento tres segundos nada más les
propongo un ejercicio tres segundos para
que cierren los ojos y se ubiquen en ese
sueño tan personal tan propio que tienen
ustedes solo 3
ahí está ya está presente lo primero que
necesitamos tenerlos presentes porque
porque lo más importante ahora va a ser
cómo hacemos para transitar este camino
desconocido para poder alcanzar ese
sueño lo primero que tenemos que hacer
por lo menos que fue una base
indispensable para empezar es visualizar
ese sueño visualizar es una herramienta
muy poderosa muy sencilla que es situar
me en un lugar en un momento particular
realmente viviendo realmente
experimentando haber alcanzado eso que
yo deseaba
una vez que yo lo tengo ahí que ya le
puse una fecha que ya le puse un lugar
sea la actividad que sea no importa lo
que tengo que hacer es el primer paso en
todo esto para transformar ese sueño en
una meta y es planificar planificar no
es otra cosa que proyectar proyectar un
camino
pero al contrario de lo que todos
piensan el camino que tenemos que
proyectar el camino que tenemos que
planificar no se hace desde este momento
hacia el futuro se hace de la manera
inversa yo tengo que plantearme ya me vi
allá en el futuro alcanzando ese anhelo
personal o colectivo que yo tengo y voy
a empezar a desandar ese camino hacia
atrás y le voy a poner metas pequeños
objetivos de mediano y de corto plazo
que me van a posibilitar a mí llegar
hasta allá de la manera que yo quiero
esos pasos esos pequeños objetivos esa
guía va a ser la hoja de ruta que yo voy
a tener cuando tenga que pasar
a la segunda parte de este camino y la
segunda parte es quizás
la parte más complicada
qué es pasar a la acción porque todos
acá sabemos que soñar no cuesta nada y
echarse en la cama debajo un árbol
simplemente a desear que las cosas pasen
lo podemos hacer todo sin mucho esfuerzo
ahora bien cuando empieza la acción
cuando yo atrás se me camino cuando yo
sé fervientemente que lo que deseo para
mí o para los míos para mi familia para
mi comunidad para el mundo
tengo que empezar a caminar y tengo que
empezar a tomar decisiones y esas
decisiones van a implicar necesariamente
dar y resignar porque cada acción que yo
voy a tomar significa una elección y
para que una elección sea verdadera yo
voy a tomar un camino y voy a dejar otro
y ahí es cuando yo verdaderamente voy a
empezar a estar poniéndome a prueba a mí
mismo a ver qué tanto yo estoy dispuesto
a dar de mí mismo para alcanzar eso que
yo quiero
ya sabemos cómo lo planificamos y ya
tenemos esa idea de seguir ese plan
ahora cada día yo tendré que levantarme
tendré que levantarme pensando en qué
acción
ese día me va a dar la oportunidad de
estar un paso más cerca de mi objetivo
un paso más cerca de mi meta ya que
quiero detenerme en algo que a mí me
parece muy importante y que tiene que
ser una guía para el ser humano
cómo vamos a encarar de qué manera vamos
a encarar cada día nuestra guía tiene
que ser lo que nosotros el deporte
llamamos la excelencia
la excelencia entendida como una regla
moral
que me auto impongo de hacer cada cosa
que me toque dando lo mejor de mí pero
sobre todo haciéndolo de la forma
correcta sin importar que alguien me
esté controlando porque al fin y al cabo
en primer lugar estaré siendo sincero
conmigo
no me estaré engañando a mí mismo si
decidí trabajar duro por algo quedarme
dos horas más en la cama
lo único estoy haciendo es engañarme a
mí mismo pero por otra parte tomar
atajos para alcanzar las metas
significaría también hacer trampas y eso
no es lícito eso no
tiene que estar en la planificación y en
la acción del ser humano porque porque
en esto no voy a estar solo
en este camino necesito también de los
demás y para que los demás me vayan
acompañando y vayan teniendo este mismo
sentimiento necesito también infundir en
ellos un sentimiento de respeto
de nuevo no hay sueños más importantes
que otros
los más importantes son los que encaró
yo mismo
y en este camino que ya voy transitando
obviamente van a ocurrir cosas muy
buenas cuando aciertos y van a ocurrir
cosas malas
cuando me equivoqué
y en este camino voy a tener
uno de los sentimientos más complicados
que tiene el ser humano que es la
incertidumbre
y la incertidumbre me pone a prueba
nuevamente y cuando llega ese momento
lo que tengo que tratar de hacer es
confiar en mí mismo en seguir esta guía
que me propuse como planificación y a su
vez estar confiado de que hacer las
cosas bien cada día me va a dar el
respaldo suficiente para seguir adelante
todo esto que venimos hablando
necesariamente tiene que estar apoyado
en algo que es fundamental y que es la
mística que es la mística que es la
confianza porque yo puedo imaginarlo
puedo visualizar lo planificarlo
tener la acción hacia allá pero si no
confío en mis cualidades si
verdaderamente no tengo esa sensación de
optimismo de que las cosas que me
propongo van a salir bien es muy difícil
ir hacia adelante es muy difícil tengo
que tener esa capacidad de reponer me
tengo que ser resiliente porque muchas
veces los resultados nos van a hacer los
que yo quiero en el trayecto sin embargo
lo que hay que analizar es si por más
que el resultado parcial no es lo que yo
quiero si realmente no estoy más cerca
el objetivo para darles algo gráfico
este equipo que en el 2019
logró ser campeón mundial
durante el trayecto de cuatro años que
llevó su planificación perdió entendido
como no ganar la final un campeonato
sudamericano dos campeonatos
panamericanos dos campeonatos mundiales
y un campeonato intercontinental
una historia de fracasos
una historia de fracasos sin embargo la
confianza el trabajo abnegado y la
decisión de seguir adelante fueron
fundamentales para poder llegar a donde
se llegó
y aquí hay algo muy especial que
pareciera que es muy difícil reconocer
pero cada uno de nosotros
tiene un talento especial inigualable
único en el mundo que lo hace particular
cada ser humano es especial tiene su
talento no es igual a nadie por eso en
esta vida y en este andar de transcurrir
detrás de los sueños como metas no me
tengo que comparar con nadie
la comparación siempre es con uno mismo
esa comparación siempre va a ser con uno
mismo
entonces yo tengo que saber si hoy soy
estoy un paso más cerca de mi meta que
ayer si soy un poco mejor de lo que era
ayer y terminará el día siendo un poco
mejor o estando más cerca de lo que
quiero
a pesar de que las cosas no hayan salido
como yo quería
por eso para nosotros es fundamental y
fue fundamental tener esa confianza
tener ese optimismo no salió esta vez
respirar profundo y seguir para adelante
no hay otra manera de encarar la vida
porque siempre vamos a tener en este
camino siempre vamos a tener disgustos
por eso confiar en el talento personal
que uno tiene es fundamental para poder
seguir adelante no hay otra forma y la
propuesta no es muy complicada es buscar
dentro de uno mismo ese talento especial
es imaginar ese sueño ese anhelo que
tengo que va a ser mi motivación para ir
adelante es visualizarlo es proyectarlo
es planificar lo y es salir hacia la
acción porque en definitiva en
definitiva los sueños pueden ocurrir o
no pero lo primero que tenemos que tener
es esa transformación de esos sueños en
metas
[Aplausos]